hi steve how are you
nice to see you um so first congrats on
the movie uh thank you for giving me
your time today uh
i like to throw a curveball at the
beginning as uh i like to just throw a
curveball so for
for people that have never seen anything
that you've done
what do you want them to watch first
probably
oh man i don't know
due date maybe
[Laughter]
i didn't know you learned that
i played
robert downey jr
steve can i can i say nothing no um
uh that's it that's a really good
question that's a very good question
that's a tricky one it depends on the
person i guess but
um i probably would just try to change
the subject if that was the uh yeah
hey let's sit down and watch one of your
movies no thanks
you're very you're very good at that the
changing of the subjects um jack
when did you decide you wanted to have
two big animated movies coming out in
the same year
i decided um on that
five years ago
it is weird though that you have two big
films this year i know
there's something i don't not that i
don't like it but like i have this ocd
thing where there's like there's things
in a row it bugs me for some reason like
i wish that there was a movie that came
out between luca and ron's gone wrong
but it's okay i'm i'm happy with with it
i made the decision
yeah no it
it's not like anyway um zach you've done
a bunch of voice recordings and i'm
curiou for both tv movies is there a
difference when you are recording for
different um
you know for a movie in it for tv is
there any difference in the voice
recording or is it all pretty much the
same
are you saying the difference between uh
a movie and a television show voice
recording yeah i butchered the way i
said it yes
no that's
it's um
uh the movie
is a lot longer process to get go or is
a lot longer process to work on not that
it's a ton of work but it's just a
longer span of time versus a tv show
where you just go do it it's very quick
this movie i don't know jack when did we
when did you start working on it
i started working on this uh back in
2017
2017 yeah okay
yeah it takes a while
uh jack true or not true you only did
this movie to be on an episode of
between two ferns
yes strictly
are we doing that
we should
no thanks okay
[Music]
okay so
being serious um for both of you guys
though what was it about the script and
story of this that really excited you to
be a part of it
um overall it was just a very um unique
story which i love i love stories that
are just you know as original as they
can be and and and it was just it was
really special
and um i love m and it touches on the
values of of friendship which i think is
really important
i uh stephen i think i liked it because
i'm all for questioning
all this technology
um
i think it's just something we should
talk about more and more and what it's
doing to us culturally and
so yeah that that's one of the reasons
that that i i like the script
one of the things about this film is
that uh it doesn't pretend that uh by
the end that if someone had invented a
bebop uh a bibot that it would just go
away i mean
it's it's uh
it's sort of honest about that you know
that technology is here to stay but i
agree with you zack that um uh
discussions have to be had you know can
you i guess could you sort of talk about
the fact that the film acknowledges that
technology is not going away and we just
have to find a way to work live with it
i like that too i like that
i mean
i think you're right it's honest if i
would prefer i would say hey can we
limit some of these technologies me
personally uh
but it's not going to go away so i think
the filmmakers approached it with with
that in mind and what may be some
solutions or at least some beginning
dialogue uh can be spun from a movie
like this you know
it's just a it's
it's also a very
well animated
uh
uh
movie and to me the magic of these
movies are whatever the artists do with
their eyes
and how they draw the facial facial
expressions and that to me is the most
miraculous thing the voice of it is
interesting but they take our voice and
then they they amplify it uh with
animation and i always find that it is a
very interesting part of being a part of
this process as you get to watch that
thing go down which is neat
yeah also the animation in this is you
know beautiful to look at for both of
you what i mean what was it like
actually watching the finished film when
you're a part of something like this
because it must be amazing
it is so amazing i love this this
animation specifically because
it's there's something that feels really
classic about it
um
but it's very it's super beautiful the
colors and and and the animators did a
really amazing job
um so yeah it feels really good it feels
really cool because it's like
uh it's it's
it's pretty unanimous like you you can't
really you can't really tell what it's
gonna look like
um
just by recording your voice in the in
the beginning process because you can't
really you're not looking at the
animation the animation hasn't really
been done yet um
so it's pretty cool in opposition to
doing a live action movie where you know
you're there and there's vision boards
and you can talk to it's it's much
different
zach your reaction
it's not going to blend out what were we
talking about
honestly i got so distracted by the
sanitizer nap thing that's on the table
here and i started thinking about
something
um this reminds me of class and that i'm
in school again um
what was the question i'm sorry stephen
uh
let's move on to a different question
what is your reaction
it was just your
yeah i mean i'm with jack on that i did
hear i was paying attention to jack's
answer he's right there's
right
you see you see some artwork in the
beginning
and then they slowly
start showing you some scenes but it's
still kind of uh
disjointed and then you get to see the
final thing and it is always a
whoa how you know you just do your
little song and dance but then there's
hundreds of other people doing their
song and dancing it all comes together
and it's it's it's neat it's neat to see
it really is
with a lot of animated uh projects
people don't record together but i read
that you guys actually did record
together at uh at a certain point um am
i wrong about this or uh did you guys
actually at one point record together
did you say that yeah we we uh we did
record together which was actually
pretty fun because i'd never actually
been able to do that
uh on an animated movie
yeah what was that like
i would think that it's much better if
you could get two people in the room
together just so you can rip off each
other yeah
i think that was a really good idea on
um
the
writers and and producers and director
part um because
yeah like you said you never really get
that opportunity to do that in animation
but it we we worked really well together
the banter and and being able to look at
zach when we were doing it felt more
genuine maybe
and jack and i have been best friends
ever since we've spent most weekends
together right jack yeah most weekends
we did a summer camp together
in auckland summer camp together yeah
yeah we
[Laughter]
every day
yep at least we try to yeah by the way
the last
zach i do have an individual question
for you um you hosted snl twice i
believe and in one of the episodes you
shaved your beard on live tv
and i'm just curious whose idea what was
that your idea because i did love that
you did and then wore a fake beard at
the end
we we shaved it for a sketch
for the uh for a sketch and then we put
the beard back on for another sketch and
yeah i don't really remember how it went
down but i think that was just because
we were doing a sketch that required uh
a mustache and so i just said let's just
shave it off and then put it back on i
think that's how it went down
but it's it's that's great tv jack you
should watch the episode when you get a
chance i got to stop
i'm just going to say thank you so much
i hope the movie's a huge hit good luck
with the rest of your interviews
thank you mr swine tribe